mein leben ich brauche noch 1 52
sekunden 50 sekunden brauchen noch den
einen letzten check point
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge ja
und ich spiele heute minecraft popstar
wird gerade voll ich bin heute minecraft
online und zwar spielen wir im blick auf
dem playmate
problematik bekommst du aber sobald
serbien heute mit dabei ist er ob salam
alte
doktor mont ex-profi frontex oder auch
monster
unter anderem bekannt durch seinen
bushido disc und
avantes und in paris hilton ist es auch
um die welt gegangen
wie viel geld gemacht damals
war adolf steiger sparraten damals durch
den nicht gedealt
vollständig gedeckt
warum besteht nicht damals war der
dealer
ok jetzt
bitte ja letzte ich glaube ich erst
einmal job liegt gebracht auf einem
kanal und hab ich mir so einen
peinlichen fällige leistung auf die
ganze zeit im kreis gelaufen als ich bin
im kreis gelaufen 45 mal ohne es zu
merken habe mich gewundert warum die
spritze sind alter das war sehr peinlich
man ja ich werde immer noch ein bisschen
droht in meiner seele wenn nicht daran
denkt dass damals war in gettorf kreis
mittlerweile bin ich hier straight
online
und beim grand und ich feiere die lions
vom rapper
frontex
brightness ich sehe aber gar nicht so
gut brille fielmann kunden schätzen
wie viel man ja dann geht's
los man so ohne impressum dann geht es
wenn du willst die fielmann ag zu
schlecker haben wenn du viel witz
schlecker schlecker ist günstig ja wenn
du
wenn du viel haben willst du musst zu
schlecker gehen da gibt's nämlich die
sachen günstiger
ja ja wirklich
leute ich wollte noch einen sache sagen
zwar jetzt wahrscheinlich gemerkt dass
der letzte videos nicht so regelmäßig
kamen wollte dazu noch kurz sagen woran
es liegt dass ist nicht natürlich
wundert ich hab momentan eine ultra
übertrafen mega brutal viel in meiner
uni zu tun hat ist schon mal eine stream
gesagt das heißt manche buben
ludwig aber den ganzen abend schon lange
nicht die ganze flut an stadt gut ich
habe einfach viel zu tun habt ihr schon
mal im stream gesagt dieses vielen
zuschauer werden schon wissen
alle anderen können zuschauer werden die
tools punkte vorausgesagt freue ich mich
immer wenn der partie aber gucken von
mir
wie gesagt ich momentan einfach mega
viel mit der union deswegen sollte nicht
das gefühl bekommen dass ich euch
irgendwie vergessen hätte aber ich habe
einfach wirklich keine zeit und keine
kraft mehr wenn juni von der und nach
hause kommen und ja dann war ich aber
zwölf stunden beispielsweise meine uni
das ist jetzt keine ausnahme den letzten
tagen dass ich von 10 bis 10 so an der
uni will und dann im rahmen zu hause und
macht krank und ist ein frosch
verwandelt haben
du hast du wolltest dich auf den
vorstandsvorsitzenden posten bei
schlecker bewerben erzähl mal brauchen
wir dafür geeignet ist also ich bin
dafür eignet weil ich gute arbeit bringe
ich bin sehr
offen die mitarbeiter natürlich ich habe
selbst mal eine kleine kinder begleitet
ist ja sehr gut stern grundlegend bohren
und wir wissen ja alle wissen alle dass
das arbeiten wenn man bei schlecker
nichts anderes ist als eine kindergruppe
zu betreuen weil die alle ich glaube
übrigens steckers pleite oder gibt es
vielleicht gibts läckerli
dann bewirbst du dich woanders tut mir
leid ich hab' ich schlecker gesagt ich
meinte natürlich
sex
goldman
der verkauf gold und holte casting
okay wir sind auf platz eins und zwar
jeweils wie rasieren das game ja
passieren das game sowie
soviel der barbier von einem
amerikanischen rapper möchte dass meine
ich glaub du nachher noch ein bisschen
leise bescheid ihr müsst entschuldigen
ich bin nämlich nicht darum mich zu
huldigen im vorigen huldigen läuft
eigentlich heute zeitlich so wirklich
auf uns so viel scheiße erzähle euch max
das ist etwas mit mir
geschafft okay okay okay es geschafft er
hat es geschafft daten von der bahn aber
hier
als freund alter läufer mir ich könnte
jetzt erstmals so eine runde beenden
war es nämlich wichtig heute denn ich
denke ich bin der größte
in diesem spielmodus hat nämlich letzte
mal sucht um im kreis gelaufen und es
hat mich so geehrt
es wird aber knapp wenn ich die runde
beendet da muss ich gas geben und nicht
so spielen das ist
fix lucky alter ich glaube man muss sich
auf dem server muss ist der weiß ein
bisschen selbst gewöhnen ich habe meine
ersten 20 plätze glaube ich nur lag nur
an lucky oder nothing happens bekommen
der sprung ist
jetzt sind die schwierigen passage
endlich geschafft das geht eigentlich
auch hier alles
noch einmal
pro 8 von 10 chf 150 haben wir noch aber
darum ist auch noch ein richtig großer
parcours oder oder was meinst du nicht
so ich bin ich noch nie so eine
besichtigung alter 215 oft bei dir
spielt so oft im blick
drittels nein ich werde wahrscheinlich
trifft es immer ich glaube ich zum
ersten mal meinem leben gerade von
diesen über an diesem einen teenager der
teen vorbeigeflogen hier treffe ich dann
ist instinktiv immer irgendwie heute
nicht vor der junge mann nach
warum ihren schreien sonst durch ein
offen besser
die dinge auch nicht mehr
als ob ich diesen letzten um man ich
schaff's glaube ich echt nicht das ding
zu beenden ich würde so gerne sowohl
offene als
auch sms sms im game
ist doch egal ich habe lag ich hab lucky
rennen mein leben ich brauche auf 1 56
sekunden 50 sekunden brauchen noch den
einen letzten check point mac point des
parks du mecklenburg vorpommern sei auf
einer seite
gehört woher oder nein blut schneller 36
sekunden heute das wird knapp ja aber
läuft läuft soweit läuft soweit das wird
richtig knapp mein gott oh mein gott oh
mein gott
da vor allem ist das ziel
die alter wie knapp das ist 22 sekunden
und ich komme noch ins ziel kommen wir
noch etwas kräften darf den main kinzig
zweite aufnahme
schaukel gang telegate
flyer ist wirklich orientiere
los geht's jetzt gibt es ein selfmade
man weiß ja schon wie es geht naja ich
für alle andere leute die da den modus
noch gar nicht kennen weil ich erst
einmal gebraucht habe es tut mir leid
das ist verdeckte briten sofort zu
erklären früh zu erklären war nicht
alter bis hier abgeht
hu
alter übertreibt jamaran anfang ist hat
dieses jahr acht minuten lang ziel erst
am ende in dem sie zu kommen da kriegt
man mich zieht es ins ziel zu kommen wie
der name schon schwer keine letzten ist
es das ziel ins ziel zu kommen und wenn
man ins ziel kommt kriegt man diese die
armut die ihr inventar sieht ist so ein
kleines gimmick kriegt man und ob als
geschenk
als auch weihnachten so viel zum thema
geschäfts klar werden dass und ja am
ende ist eine kriegsbeginns runde und
man hat in der regel das bessere
equipment wenn man weiter gekommen ist
aber ist halt immer ein bisschen glück
abhängig und walter weiß der weiß nicht
ganz so weißt du wieviel blöcke du
hinter mir war es so 100 oder so der
hafer und
kann trotzdem sein dass das dass man am
besten ist man hat auch wenn man 100
blöcke zurückliegt wie jetzt beim atx er
hat einfach eine tierärztin steinstraße
schon krass op ist schon eine ganz
andere sache weil die irgend sowas wie
schutzeffekt hat oder so habe ich mal
gelesen weiß bestimmt schreibt mir das
mal in die kommentare also ich habe
gelesen dass die die az über die
rüstungs punkte hinaus irgend so eine
art schutz entscheid mit hat die man was
man nicht sieht
sollen wir uns mal kurz bieten nicht
dass das leute nicht denken das b team
der luft
ein bisschen
und die sagen das ist unglaublich nein
als
bassist und
myvideo drei weiß abgestürzt alter
so leute ich hab mir jetzt die sache
überlegt wir werden es so machen dass
ich die rolle trotzdem aber damit ihr
noch ein kleinen kampf am ende hat man
jetzt einfach eine runde krieg so wie
games.com doch einfach noch mal kurz auf
den gomez server so leute da sind wir
hier auf der map und das lustige ist
diese kurs geht gibt es einst du einst
genauso auch als deathmatch map
aufnehmen das heißt wir eigentlich sehr
sehr realitätsnah nun dass es halt nicht
diese kosten jetzt mit dem ganzen guten
stoff sondern man es doch selbst wollen
muss aber die map ist genau die gleiche
man
hat ja kommen sie auf winter genauso wie
im leben daraus man halt der schwede der
die so richtig für richtig viel
angestellt
wird so sah das ist denn ihr an die tu
dich will ich wecken überdies
habe die weisheit wenn wir jetzt
vielleicht eine comic gibt dann combo
dann habe ich ein problem mit hamburg
vom der junge
alter der nockberge jetzt aber hat den
gold apfel nice das ist gut sehr gut
auch wenn ich mich sehr gerne mit er
damit er damit klar damit unten rein
al-islam oben war noch ganz frisch guck
mal kurz in die kiste rein nein
da wo
ich bin bei diesem rondell rondell sowie
bordell
hinter mir wirklich
noch
so alt er das war auch richtig riskant
man aber ich hab dem triple von tripolis
gegeben deswegen gegen das vier tonnen
gold ab jetzt jetzt gold auf frist für
das fest dahinter geht es ab meinte 'du
bist du hinter dir seiner
wieso hab ich da stand ich auf der
einzig bin ein randy hatte ich
mal kurz mal den typen hier hey
goldmann dann
okay david cvp
ok
news flow von eur 3 da haben wir noch
ein bisschen tnt und bereit ist es für
eine first drive runde eigentlich ganz
saftig muss ich sagen gefällt mir nicht
saftig die usa ist schnitzel
ok ich
würdige 23
der film beginnt auch jetzt gleich jetzt
gibt es recht schnell dass den death
match kommt auch kommt gar nicht
hinterher aber wussten jetzt der andere
musst du jetzt der andere typ ich
wünsche ihnen gern noch wegklatschen
damit wir vorher schon mal die dinge
klären können neben klären muss im leben
zum beispiel dass wir einfach dann
wollen wir wollen machen können in der
menschenkette auch einer von uns
gegangen da bist du okay
attacke hilfe
ok also wirklich gute leute kennen kann
er was erzählen
malta ist ja auch hier mord auf
gehobenem serviert wird direkt banden so
oder uns beigebracht
hatte ok dann machen wir machen jetzt
monitor
kompass zu sehen doch
rentabilität noch da ist ja noch eine ja
ich team mit dem ich das mit dem fenster
nichts ausmachen doch mich herzlich
verstanden teams als rico machen
denn sie machen
ich würde den ich bin dauernd alte
albert stahel wo ich bin gleich so was
von da und ich bin ich richtig dauern
das bedauern
naja leute war trotzdem recht lustige
combo hat mir ganz gut gefallen die auch
vom mega chillig irgendwie ganz anderer
modus haben wir nachts auf der sich auch
gefallen hat dann lasst gerne einen
daumen nach oben da
schreibt wie gesagt in die kommentare
wie das ist mit welchen effekt die
letzten endes hat und check meinte ob
der es in der beschreibung verlinkt
oberster link unbedingt abchecken hoch
hat unter anderem auf seinen channel die
route zum stein der weisen und zum
jungbrunnen da gehört also kann man auch
einfach mal vorbeischauen wie gesagt wir
sehen uns ansonsten beim nächsten video
wieder haut rein macht es gut und scharf